if women can wear makeup in their dating
profiles men should be able to lie about
their height and income
women can wear makeup men should be able
to lie about their height and income
wrong again what no they shouldn't have
mentioned it you should never lie I
don't I don't think that make I mean I
know that you don't wear makeup you sort
of wake up naturally but some women do
wear makeup and it's not a lie to wear
makeup it accentuates I would say maybe
underlying Beauty
I I think that some women take it so far
maybe I was answering in the context of
like how I see makeup where it's I don't
wear a lot unless I'm on camera but even
that is like I look the same guys
um but there are some people I feel
totally different you can completely
like the way that people Contour their
face look you look like a totally
different person with that I'm like okay
that's like disingenuous I always find
women who wear a lot of makeup yeah I
find it doesn't make them look better
even if they're a kind of plain Jane
looking yeah because I like I don't know
I I am attracted to reality I like
reality more than fantasy and so if I
see a nice girl who is you know just
confident and naturally beautiful in
whatever way she is I'm going to find
that much more attractive than some
person who's you know had plastic
surgery to look like a Kardashian or
something but it's interesting how many
women go to such lengths to completely
like change everything about themselves
whether it be like with the plastic
surgery I mean that new thing if you've
seen like the buccal fat surgery
they're sucking fat out of your cheeks
to make you
oh that looks like that yeah so like so
I have like a Perpetual like a duck face
like going to those kinds of like
ridiculous links and then all the caked
on makeup yeah and then and then you run
into them
yeah and the fake eyelashes that kind of
look like caterpillars all of that where
it's like you're going to such links and
then you wonder why guys like
say like oh like no girl looks like her
dating profile like this is so crazy
like I just want her to be natural but
then women have gone so far it's very
weird but you got it right I did I don't
think that men should lie but I also
think women need to stop editing their
photos they need to stop taking on
makeup it's better for your skin too
yeah the other thing I mean maybe you'll
say yes it does matter but
you're very successful in your own right
would it really matter if a guy
puffed up his salary on a dating profile
maybe it would I don't know people are
if it comes down to integrity
but also you know when dating profiles
don't really talk about their salary hmm
if it was height
yeah if you're just kind of like I'm a
half an inch taller that's fine five
foot I'm five foot two and three
quarters but I say six feet just Round
Up Just round up that's fine I round up
to six four actually well that's
impressive good for you yeah but if it's
like you're five seven and you're saying
you're six foot's like okay now you're
just catfishing yeah
um
but it's so difficult because on many
dating profiles it's so General so it's
like a lot of these statements you can't
really tell me until you actually talk
to the person but so many people on
dating apps they don't actually go on
dates that's the thing they'll talk for
months because it's a game what yes oh
no people don't go on dates from dating
apps very few of them do you sit around
because it's a game you swipe you get
the instant gratification you might talk
so someone likes me someone thinks I'm
cute yes exactly you talk and you'll
never meet up and I have friends that
are you know we'll try to you know oh I
want to go out with this guy or whatever
and they'll try to make it happen with
like in three to four days because
obviously you don't want to go out with
somebody maybe he's a serial killer yeah
um but yeah that's I I don't remember
what the stats are but it's like it'll
be weeks or months before they even get
around to going out I just missed dating
apps I just missed it sweet little Elise
and I got back together right okay we're
coming out so I I missed I never was on
one yeah I have friends who've done them
all the time
to get me to text my wife back to get me
to text my employers to get me to text
myself to get to text you back to really
to text my dear friends I it takes a
days and days and days yeah and I think
people now for recreation will go on to
just text strangers for months with no
point other than that in additional
whatsoever wow so because of that I
think a lot of people are very relaxed
with what they put on there because
those conversations very rarely have any
kind of substance it's so it's like oh
you and often like I was on a podcast
recently and the guy asked me to like
look at his profile like oh would you
rate it or something like that and I've
had my guy friends like do very similar
things no my girlfriends too and it's
all very very general and when I look at
them I'm like why would you not you know
put everything out there basically and
like talk about your non-negotiables
like say what you're actually looking
for I saw this girl on Tick Tock who did
this whole video basically raging doing
that angry feminist rant about this guy
and she posted their conversation and he
wrote back and he was like oh you're so
beautiful she said oh my God thank you
and he said could I ask you you know
what you're looking for and her response
was
I don't really know I'm just kind of
figuring things out and so he writes
back and says Okay I want to be up front
I travel a lot for work I'm really not
sure if I want something serious right
now I'm really just looking for like
Friends with Benefits maybe if it like
moves in somebody's being honest he's
being upfront he's on the app he's like
hi I'm a dirt bag yeah I just want to
please my body exactly and like I don't
I want to use you as an instrument for
my own body yes exactly but he asked she
said I don't really care and so she he
responded honestly and then she flips
out at him and goes how dare you think
that I would do this like I'm looking
for something serious I would never like
go down to that like level yeah then be
honest you can't play both sides of it
you can't play games and expect men not
to be playing games it's a constant
double standard and so I like that
though the conclusion being women might
not know what they want yeah but they
definitely know what they don't want
yeah that's very true that is very true
with women but anyway the apps are so
gamey and if you actually want to use it
properly Dennis Breakers talked about
this a lot and he's talked to me about
it when I was still living in LA and
he's actually a big advocate for dating
apps
Dennis is a player you know Dennis just
wants everybody to get married with the
stove yeah right well I remember when I
was at prageru he was like constantly
trying to match fake people if you were
like a 20 year old whatever he was
remarried yet like let me find you
somebody like let me go to you know let
me find somebody in my community but we
were talking about dating apps and I was
kind of like oh you know they're so
stupid he was like no especially if you
are in like a liberal area he said this
is the best way to weed everybody out
but the caveat is that you have to be
intentional you have to actually put
your religion you can't be like Oh I'm a
moderate if you're actually conservative
no just say it because then the people
who are going to be angry at you and are
going to hate you you're not wasting
your time you're not wasting their time
the only people that are going to
actively be interested are like oh this
is great you're being out there get on
the dating app yes yes swipe right yep
I'm Dennis Price let's be honest and
Michael's none loophole aside
if somebody is not married by the age of
30 it's them
oh so it's saying about religious life
it could be a consecrated single or a
religious or something but put that
aside for a second if you're the kind of
person who would marry and you don't get
married by 30 it's on you
I think in many many cases
like I think about my oldest brother
I've talked about with my brothers now
he's not married he's 34. but he's
choosing not to be pisses me off he's
choosing not to because he wants to be a
celibate or he's choosing not to be
because he's just just because he you
know I don't know he's not he's not
getting married he's not getting married
yeah but you know I also look at friends
who are desperately trying who are very
very intentional with it and I you know
a couple of good friends that are like
mid-20s and are very very worried about
that who are like very deeply and
they're like are trying and I do think
that you know kind of some of it will
come down to you know how much are you
putting yourself out there and you say
that you are you're not being you know
genuine with it or you're altering
yourself to try to fit into somebody
else's idea but I don't I think it can
be a lot of things but I also know that
like the dating landscape these days is
disgusting yeah it's disgusting there's
no there because the standards and Norms
were destroyed by the libs in the 60s
and 70s no one knows what to expect
people now say we're talking we're at
different talking stages right you're
talking you don't even know what you
can't even call it dating there's a new
article oh gosh who bubble but it
was talking about gen Z's love of
situationships and how it's okay and how
gen Z should kind of like settle in this
situation ship phase and the talking
phase and how that's really positive
Frozen adolescence yes right so I do
think that a lot of it is because of
people's choices that they're making but
also how much of that is directly from
them and how much of that is from like
the social right you know societal
changes that we've had that makes it
impossible if you're if you're a woman
you're raised in a liberal environment
and you were taught a bunch of nonsense
yeah and then you were told don't have
serious relationships don't ever Choose
Love and Marriage over your career
you've got to go get some Advanced
degree to go work in the widget Factory
or study you know some super specific
nonsense to not get a job teaching it at
a university and then you end up and you
look up you finally got all your degrees
you got all your spreadsheets are done
and you're 30 and you think oh I was
lied to yeah oh well you know is it the
person's fault yeah at a certain point
you gotta get that personal
responsibility right but it's also the
whole culture every everything in the
culture your parents your school your
popular entertainment your the
scientists the everything has been lying
to you and so it takes one person to be
you raised in that environment and then
to say no I'm not going to so I think it
is a balance skill but in many cases I
do think that you know people cause
their own problems so yeah that's true
you know that's when people say I've got
all you know a thousand failed
relationships
there's a common denominator if you
haven't really dated and you've been
like very particular or you've been
focused on something else I'm like okay
that's probably something else but if
you're just